salut romain ça va ben non je sortis le
médecin je suis pas content au moins
pourquoi il n'a pas voulu me donner
antibiotiques du coup j'ai jamais guerre
dans sa réponse à quoi exactement
j'ai mal à la tête et la bouche sèche à
ras la gueule de bois quoi moi les
antibiotiques c'est pas une bonne idée
[Musique]
bon on va faire un petit jeu si je vous
dis les antibiotiques
vous me dites bien joué ça marque un
point alors du coup une deuxième
question
ça veut dire quoi pourquoi les
antibiotiques c'est pas automatique
les antibiotiques c'est pas automatique
à cause de l'antibiorésistance et donc
dernière question c'est quoi
l'antibiorésistance romain et comme plus
des trois quarts des français il ne sait
pas exactement ce que c'est
l'antibiorésistance mais comme on parle
quand même de quelque chose qui tue
vingt cinq mille personnes par an en
europe
ça mérite qu'on se penche un peu sur la
question l'antibiorésistance en gros
c'est quand les bactéries développent
des mécanismes de résistance aux
antibiotiques
c'est à dire aux médicaments qu'on
utilise pour traiter les infections
qu'elle provoque
et du coup ces médicaments qui sont
moins voire plus du tout efficace bon
vous avez une idée mais on n'est pas
forcément plus avancé on va un
antibiotique donc c'est un médicament
qui agit directement sur les bactéries
soit en les tuant soit en les empêchant
de se multiplier le médecin nous en
prescrit pour soigner une infection
alors des poumons de l'oreille de la
gorge d'une plaie par exemple mais ça ne
marche que si cette infection est causée
par des bactéries
parce que ça n'est pas efficace sur les
autres germes comme les champignons les
virus c'est pour ça qu'on n'en prend pas
quand on a la grippe est ce que c'est
une maladie virale et c'est un peu là
que les problèmes commencent quand on a
compris comment il marchait dans les
années 30 on les a utilisés pour soigner
des maladies mortelles qui était
jusque-là incurables comme la peste ou
la tuberculose mais aussi plein d'autres
maladies infectieuses et comme ils sont
pas considérés comme dangereux comme ils
sont généralement bien toléré on les a
beaucoup utilisé trop même et mal
juste un exemple on s'est mis à en
prendre à chaque fois qu'on avait une
angine ou presque alors que 70% des
jeans sont posés par un virus et pas par
une bactérie
on en a même donné aux animaux d'élevage
pour les faire grossir plus vite et ils
ont eux aussi développer des bactéries
résistantes qu'on a ensuite mangé en
fait le premier problème c'est que les
bactéries quand on les agresse elles
réagissent en s'adaptant elles peuvent
muter pour que les antibiotiques ne
puisse plus fixé dessus par exemple il y
en a aussi qui arrivent à détruire les
molécules des antibiotiques
bref elle développe différents
mécanismes de défense et elles
deviennent résistantes
l'autre problème c'est que quand on
prend des antibiotiques les bactéries
qui sont sensibles elles disparaissent
mais celles qui sont résistantes elles
restent elles se multiplient et
qu'ensuite elles peuvent transmettre le
gène de la résistance à d'autres
bactéries
même s'ils ne sont pas de la même
famille le risque c'est qu'au bout d'un
moment les antibiotiques ne soient plus
du tout efficace ça voudrait dire qu'une
blessure banale qui s'infectent aucune
infection qu'on considère aujourd'hui
comme bénigne elle pourrait devenir
mortel parce qu'on aurait plus de
médicaments pour les traiter on appelle
ça une impasse thérapeutique
d'après un rapport commandé par le
gouvernement britannique les bactéries
résistantes tuent aujourd'hui 700 mille
personnes dans le monde chaque année et
selon pourrait atteindre 10 millions de
morts par an en 2050 si on trouve pas de
solution alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
oui parce que calmez vous on peut faire
quelque chose dès ses seins de limiter
la circulation des bactéries résistantes
avec des mesures d'hygiène 2 de trouver
des nouveaux moyens de lutter contre les
infections bactériennes 3 de calmer le
jeu sur l'utilisation des antibiotiques
pour limiter les résistances en
attendant d'avoir trouvé des nouveaux
moyens ok oui non concrètement plus on
utilise d'antibiotiques plus on donne la
possibilité aux bactéries de développer
des résistances
donc il faut les utiliser moins souvent
et surtout le mieux possible
d'abord les médecins ont des moyens pour
déterminer si les antibiotiques sont
nécessaires et surtout lequel est
efficace sur la bactérie en cause en cas
d'infection ensuite il faut développer
des nouveaux antibiotiques auxquels les
bactéries ne sont pas résistantes
on n'a pas sorti de nouvelles familles
d'antibiotiques depuis 2000
c'est en cours il faut aussi trouver
d'autres moyens de lutter contre les
infections et là dessus la recherche a
aussi des pistes donc les choses sont
mises en place au niveau des médecins et
des chercheurs mais nous en attendant on
a aussi des réflexes à prendre ou des
habitudes à perdre ou les deux ne prenez
pas des antibiotiques si on ne vous en a
pas prescrit et n'en donnait pas aux
autres non plus si vous en reste dans
une boîte les gardait pas pour une
prochaine fois
attention les jetez pas à la poubelle
les médicaments c'est pas des déchets
comme les autres ils ont un traitement
spécial pour éviter qu'on les retrouve
dans l'environnement
quand il vous en reste ramené à la
pharmacie qui soient périmés ou pas qui
sont obligés de vous les reprendre
n'arrêtez pas votre traitement avant la
fin au bout de deux jours vos symptômes
ont peut-être disparu mais il reste des
bactéries donc aller jusqu'au bout parce
que oui
l'idée c'est d'en prendre moins souvent
mais quand vous en prenez prenez les
biens sinon ça alors les choses
dans un même ordre d'idée respectez bien
les doses prescrites c'est le traitement
est pas efficace et ça revient à prendre
des antibiotiques pour rien ont valu que
ce n'est pas une bonne idée si vous avez
un doute sur la dose sur la durée du
traitement si vous avez perdu votre
ordonnance ou j'sais pas quoi demander à
votre médecin ou à votre pharmacien
faites pas votre pote dans votre coin
voilà vous savez maintenant pourquoi les
antibiotiques c'est pas automatique
mini systématique ni plein d'autres
trucs en ic et vous savez surtout quoi
faire et ne pas faire avec
du coup dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là mettez vous
bien et surtout portée
[Musique]